salut à tous 34 points en moins de 17
minutes c'est ce qu'a fait lucas garza
la semaine dernière face à iowa state le
joueur de iowa qui est clairement le
gros joueur de ce début de saison en n 6
de belley le joueur dominant le pivot
d'iowa c'est de lui dont on va parler
c'est lui qu'on a choisi pour notre
premier scouting report de cette saison
et pour cela chaque oeil romain ben et
maxime salut les gars du salut bonjour
donc pour ce beau bébé né roman vous les
connaissez maxime et notre membre de
l'équipe envergure qui se concentre sur
les conférence big ten et big is
notamment ainsi que des autres voire
conférence atlantique ten aussi
puisqu'on un peu réparti les conférences
est signée entre entre les différentes
personnes de l'équipe donc voilà maxime
spécialiste de la conférence où évolue
le cas garza depuis maintenant plus de
trois ans en est ainsi de belley c'est
l'épisode 3 de 700 est d'envergure et
ses prix
alors luca garza romain on va commencer
par une brève introduction sur le profil
de ce joueur puisque le but c'est aussi
de le faire connaître
vous pouvez aller voir les vidéos sur
nos réseaux sociaux mais de le faire
connaître des personnes qui n'ont jamais
vu jouer donc décrit nous un peu le
style de jeu style de joueurs alors né
sur un sur un joueur qui est un petit
peu un enfant de la diaspora yougoslavie
les double nationalité slovène slovène
et bosnienne nés en 98
donc il est quand même déjà il est déjà
22 22 22 22 ans cette année les seniors
la joueur un joueur très mature sous
plein d'aspects famille de basketteurs
il est fin d'année 98 famille de
basketteurs sont son jeu son père a joué
un dossier sa mère était international
yougoslave son grand père a joué en
initier à hawaï ensuite dans dans le
référencement on continue avec son oncle
pour les plus anciens d'entre vous à
libé kovic qui a joué origone state et
qui est le meilleur marqueur de
l'histoire de l'équipe nationale de
slovénie son cousin a joué à st john's
également donc il ya un vrai un vrai big
love oui il ya un vrai pedigree il est
donc dans sa quatrième année iowa state
iowa pardo où la notion quatrième année
à rio a donc dans la dans la mitaine
avec des stats en progression constante
et un début de saison cette année plus
que plus que solide et statistiquement
et dans l'impact qu'il peut avoir c'est
une espèce de poste 5 déjà pour c'est un
jouet de m 117 kg voilà c'est plutôt on
est on est plutôt dans le dans le modèle
genre de meubles quand vous allez dans
les magasins il faut faire transporter
car c'est pas c'est pas vraiment du 10
août sur celle sur sur le volume
physique pas forcément d'une grande
grande mobilité mais beaucoup rire par
contre tout ce qui est nord-sud il peut
le faire sans trop de problème est ouest
c'est un peu plus compliqué très dense
dont jeu de transition intéressant parce
que ça peut ça peut impacter et poster
assez vite mais surtout bon il repose
quand même son début de saison sur sur
l'adresse à trois points qui est un
petit peu un petit peu scandaleuse pour
un grand il n'est pas nécessairement sur
un gros volume de tir mais il est pas
loin des 70 % à 3 points à l'heure
actuelle il a pris 16 tirs en cinq
matches ce n'est pas énorme mais bon ça
reste ça reste aujourd'hui un joueur qui
il faut déjà l'année dernière pour
donner des volumes plus conséquent sur
toute une saison il shoote à quasiment
36% à 3 points ce qui est évidemment
très solide pour quelqu'un de son
gabarit de sa taille
ben pour rajouter à cette présentation
quelles caractéristiques physiques ou
techniques tu ferait ressortir en termes
de gros points forts du côté de tout le
gard comme le notait c'est pour un
athlète explosif mais moi je trouve que
ce qui m'a impressionné chez lui qu'à
gaza sexuelle mâle est fluide
il est capable de lui comprend le tempo
des matches il est capable de s'adapter
à la vitesse de ses gardes
ce qui est vraiment pas ce que l'apanage
de tous les groupes et les très très
gracieux dans son jeu il est capable de
jouer de finesse avec des dégâts qui
n'ont pas nécessairement ces outils là
donc est capable de bien scoré au poste
bas
de plusieurs façons différentes avec des
opérateurs avec des spin move il a
vraiment tout l'arsenal
un autre truc qui m'a beaucoup
impressionné moi quand j'ai regardé du
film sur lui c'est la vitesse de sa
gâchette et décoche son tir très très
très rapidement surtout son tir à trois
points c'est quelque chose qui est qui
qui va plaire à beaucoup d'équipés mais
ici il ya probablement de fin de la
tonicité au niveau du dos de même du
puce en général pour déclencher un tir
aussi rapide on y reviendra plus tard
pour une stat pour illustrer ce que tu
disais par rapport à son jeu proche du
cercle
c'est pas vraiment un joueur qui joue au
dessus du cercle joue plus haut non non
non non pas ce sommet mais mais je
suppose pour pour rassurer aussi sus
caraman disait moi j'ai vu surtout face
à western illinois quelques signes
encourageants de mobilité est ouest il y
voit lui mettais des écrans il ya sortie
du joueur sortie d'écran laid cette
mobilité là elle est pas encore au point
mais s'est amélioré de guy lafleur
alors justement le contexte dans lequel
il joue c'est pour ça entre autres que
que maxime est là qui qui regardent les
matchs d'iowa de près depuis depuis au
moins depuis l'année dernière même avant
probablement commençons quel est le rôle
de luca garza dans cette équipe comment
il est entouré ça c'est intéressant
aussi pour évaluer un joueur yoann et a
sûrement le meilleur joueur de hand
c'est un des meilleurs jeunes tués et il
a entouré être plus ment ou presque de
shooter avec os quand même un potentiel
se garant pour le prochain pour la
prochaine draft qui est un excellent
shooteur surtout en début d'année il a
une réussite aussi insolente que fait de
nous des gardes ça parce que je crois
qu'il ya à 55% à 3 points sur début
d'année vous avez sur le meilleur le
meilleur shooteur de la victime dany n'a
rien expliqué frédéric dont qui
l'entouré ça lui permet en fait de
pouvoir prendre ces positions à
l'intérieur mais perd très peu de
ballons
et une fois qu'il a pris cette position
intérieure et que potentiellement que là
potentiellement de doubler est entourée
d'excellents autour de lui et john
boehner comme jordan barnes qui était
blessé l'année dernière et qui peut
apporter toute son expérience je sais
qu'elle ne chante ces unions qui arrive
à remettre en place tant dans le besoin
s'en fait sentir
maxime pour ceux qui qui connaissent pas
le championnat n 6 iowa clairement c'est
un des candidats au titre cette année
badens de tous les rancunes de pré
season il était top 10 voire même top 5
et aujourd'hui ils sont rentrés
troisième donc surtout les est donc
clairement ils font partie des favoris
c'est pas loin d'être une première pour
eux parce que ils ont pas atteint ne
serait-ce que l'élite ait depuis plus de
30 ans donc ce n'est pas qu'une femme
qui habituent être être dans la lumière
et avec un coach comme comme 30 mc café
je pense qu'ils ont une bonne chance moi
c'est une des équipes que je suis le
plus entre qu'avec pour compléter sur
gaza ce qui est intéressant on le sait
c'est d'observer la défense sur pick'n
roll notamment comment quel type de
défense comme on le fait défendent du
côté des riaux assure sur pick'n roll
est ce que on va faire une prise à deux
est ce qu'on va plutôt le drop et le
laisser près du cercle comment ça défend
franchement ça dépend vraiment des
forces et des faiblesses de l'équipe
adverse
c'est quand même une défense qui
s'adapte plutôt bien on force de
l'adversaire et qui arrive qu'ils qui
laissent plus qu'ailleurs ça plutôt d'
europe et on est plutôt sur ce sur ce
style de défense donc maintenant aussi
clairement ses épis l'entouré quand même
de très d'assez bons défenseurs donc
donc ça lui permet lui aussi de se
cacher c'est avec une de ses cachets ou
pas mais en tout cas ça qu'une de ses
de ses principaux défauts comme l'a
rappelé ben et c'est quand même sa
défense sa défense comme contre légaux
rapides il a du mal latéralement ce
latéral et donc ça n'empêche pas de
mettre des contres évidemment vu qu'il
reste près du cercle
l'année passée on était à 6 % de deux
contres donc c'est le pourcentage de
tirs adverses qui est contré par par le
joueur lorsqu'il est sur le terrain on
va dire que pour les grands ça aussi
entre généralement 3 4% et 10 12% pour
les excellents contre hurd et en ce
début d'année même si c'est que peu
représentatif avec cinq matches et déjà
il est haï l'a9 10 pour son calme ouais
c'est ça elle lui pour cent et millas et
abc effectivement à l'heure où on
enregistre il était il était pour cent
et demi sur les caractéristiques
techniques on va rentrer vraiment dans
le pré 6 e romain c'est un joueur qui
shoote à j'avais le chiffre sous les
yeux tout à l'heure 71 % je parle de
l'année dernière près du cercle
alors qu'on la dit il et il est
complètement en dessous du cercle il
donne qu'assez rarement je vais pouvoir
vous sortir son nombre de dunk l'année
dernière née mais s'était pas produite
après je reviens juste sur ce conte sur
un portique de hockey avant iowa de
manière assez pragmatique fait aussi
beaucoup d'alternance défensive zone
zone etc etc qui permet de cacher un peu
le manque de mobilité du du garçon en
sachant que défensivement c'est un
joueur que je trouve moi alors limité
dans la mobilité un petit peu mais par
contre il sert très très bien du bas du
corps c'est à dire que c'est pas il fait
pas partie de ces joueurs intérieurs
moins athlétique ou un peu plus lourds
qui vont beaucoup poussé servir des bras
et compagnie c'est vrai mais et
utilisent très bien le bas de son corps
ce qui fait qu'il arriva à défendre y
compris sur les prises de position
commune a de l'impact qui vont après
c'est pareil c'est plus mature aussi que
la plupart des mecs qui jouent donc il a
il a quand même des qualités techniques
défensives après pour en revenir sur la
pac près du cercle il a il ya un arsenal
offensif très intéressant d un vrai
impact au robot rov
je sais j'ai plus les chiffres en tête
sur ce qui prend cette année en terme
d'heures bouron francis mais c'était
assez accablant passé il est à 12% il à
4,2 rebonds de moyenne cette année bon
c'est sur cinq matches c'est peut-être
pas forcément révélateur l'an dernier en
31 matches au programme 3 6 ce qui est
énorme
la limite que la limite que je lui
trouve à l'heure actuelle c'est pour moi
il est très main droite voire peut-être
un peu trop
il arrive à des excès un petit peu mais
quand ils se retrouvent à tourner sur la
mauvaise épaules à savoir l'épaule
droite régulièrement il ya tendance un
petit peu mettre la tête à s'enferrer
dans le joueur c'est à dire qu'il
apprend correct de désaxer passer au
dessus de la tête et vraiment d'aller
chercher quelque chose qui est au delà
de l'épaule et je suis pas si je suis
clairement ce qu'ils expliquent et
pourtant il a une bonne main gauche
ouais il est bonne à gauche mais dans la
plupart des choses que je vois il a
quand même tendance à avoir pressé
naturel est droitier as composé vraiment
sur cette main droite vrai impact pour
vont capable de jouer au poste bas lors
de deux façons différentes donc sur la
prise de position et du duel dans le
fait seule pile est capable de faire des
choses aussi parce que il va partir avec
un petit peu de vitesse et arrêté un mec
de 110 kg qu'un petit peu de qui part de
4 5 mètres en ville comme ça qui met
l'épaule d'abord vous dire c'est pas
forcément très amusant à faire et dans
le jeu de transition c'est pareil c'est
ce qu'on appelle un flanc tribord
annonce alors qu'il est capable vraiment
de courir et d'aller d'aller d'aller
d'alice mais tout de suite près du
cercle et bombes encore une fois c'est
pareil si on n'a pas un transpalette
pour le déplacer c'est vite compliqué
donc il a une capacité à alterner en
fait le jeu qui peut le rendre très
intéressant ce que ben a inévitablement
si vous faites un petit peu l'impasse
après sur tout ce qui est collaboration
défensif sur les écrans sur lesquels il
est impliqué sur des écrans porteront
porter il s'écarte et il sanctionne donc
aujourd'hui l'intelligence de jeu et la
dimension physique le fait qu'il soit un
peu plus mature que que la plupart des
joueurs qu'ils rencontrent fait qu
inévitablement il est dans une situation
où j'ai rapax domine mais on peut le
dire s'il est en tout cas au dessus de
ce que ce qu'on peut faire face à lui y
compris phase aller avec plus athlétique
parce qu'une alternance dans son jeu
pour ça que moi je pense qu'il est il
est mature aujourd'hui la question du
plafond cela posera peut-être après il
est mature aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
jouer pour pouvoir verser
un mec typiquement on le met dans une
équipe pro aujourd'hui il est capable de
l'idh est capable de tout de suite
efficace et il fait ce qu'il sait faire
ce qui est une qualité que j'aime
beaucoup chez les joueurs exactement il
sort pas de son rôle justement ben à
propos de rôle
j'aime je sais que tu tu regarde
beaucoup les capacités de vision de jeu
de passes et cetera de d'être malin dans
le fait de poser des écrans comment tu
le l'évaluent gars a de ce point de vue
là bas il s'est beaucoup amélioré depuis
l'année dernière
c'est un joueur que je suis depuis
peut-être deux ans depuis sa saison
sophomore et s'est beaucoup améliorée je
la regardais parle en entrevue yapi
disait que les deux choses que dans le
processus pré draft on lui a demandé
d'améliorer c'est la mobilité latéral et
son jeu de passe et il est beaucoup plus
créatif qu'il était surtout du post bat
g mais si vous voulez aller voir jérémy
un clip sûrement sur mon twitter on
hésite au poste bas ils pensent aux
périmètres ça et c'est à la défense un
peu les joueurs de périmètre les repasse
au poste bas pour deux points faciles
donc ça j'ai vraiment un jeu qui est qui
est très avancé ce genre c'est ce qu'on
appelle la boîte du feeling pour le jeu
savoir à savoir du qi c'est vraiment ça
il est trés comme des grands moyens un
pedigree il est très éduqué il est très
sophistiqué pour un gars de sa stature
et de son âge
un maxime haut niveau on va rester sur
le côté offensif est ce que tu as vu des
nouveaux des bennes en parlais tout à
l'heure un petit peu des choses
nouvelles qui l'a développé dans son
arsenal alors on sait que son rôle c'est
d'être près du panier de prendre la
position assez fort et d'aller finir
bien souvent avec la faute mais ce qui
l'a développé petit à petit d'autres
armes peut-être pour s'écarter genre de
choses
en ce début d'année par rapport par
rapport à l'année dernière je vois pas
d'énormes différences si ce n'est qu'il
fait tout encore mieux ce qui faisait
l'année dernière il est encore enfin
fait jeux potentiellement récapituler
tout ce qu'on dit ben et et romain mais
il a encore plus fort pour finir au
cercle pour prendre sa position il a un
touché qui est qui est incroyable son
moi c'est ce qui m'impressionne le plus
chez lui c'est sa manière de secours est
en mouvement car il part sur la gauche
sur sa droite il arrive à finir après
contact en étant en mouvement il pour un
big c'est quand même assez fait à
cadenasser remarquable roman tu voulais
intervenir non c'est moi que c'est moi
qui dit qu'ils approuvaient la le
commentaire sur le score réel de scoring
en mouvement c'est vraiment vraiment
quelqu'un qui se déplace bien à ascot le
gaz puis ça c'est vraiment un point qui
a un qui sait bien quelque chose qu'il a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de le pivot
n'ont pas même en biais ouais absolument
défensivement puisque offensivement on a
fait un peu le tour si on n'a pas parlé
du tir pour le moment romain on est on
est sur un joueur qui est adroit en
catch and shoot il va pas aller faire
des sorties d'écran c'est pas un joueur
qui va être très mobile plus shooteur
quoi c'était bien il n'a pas eu ma
propre pas prendre des cascades d'écran
et alors que moins du monde le sait
c'est dur c'est de manière très simple
du catch and shoot filet ouvert
ou alors des situations où il va être
sûr du papa outil va s'écarter et avoir
le capiste s écarter rapidement et armés
d'assez haut donc par contre il ya il
n'y a pas de réelle mobilité dans son
tir oui mais en revanche c'est c'est
plutôt solide au niveau de la de la
mécanique des appuis c'est à dire que
vos faut qu'ils soient plantés mais il
est
les plans des il est propre quoi ah oui
et non c'est propre c'est propre il est
planté là dessus il n'y a pas de aucune
inquiétude à avoir de ce côté là et sur
la mécanique de tir je te demande à toi
puisqu'ils étaient plus technicien dans
le swing bugs qe2 que mercy mercy de
partie de la plaque et lyon non sur la
bêtise sur les mécaniques globalement
c'est c'est assez c'est assez propre
c'est bien encore une fois c'est très
stable il ya c'est très stable il a il
ya un tir qui part peut-être un petit
peu bas mais sûr l'armée l'armée l'armée
le point de le conduire à la finition cc
suffisamment haut élevé pour être pour
être efficaces ces tarifs attirent au
dessus des gens il faut quand même de 11
donc même si l'armée un petit peu devant
lui sa montre relativement bien mon
questionnement il est plus par rapport
aux par rapport à son à son adresse de
balle aux lancers francs que je trouve
pas que je trouve pas paradoxalement que
feront pas extraordinaire absolument
en carrière puisqu'on va rester
là-dessus en carrière il a 70% sur un
peu plus de futurs quasiment 500
tentatives
ce qui est bien mais pas kata mai mais
s'est on pourrait s'attendre à mieux de
la part d'un joueur qui a un toucher
intéressant en fait 70 % c'est à
travailler effectivement on va passer
aux à la défense je commençais par un
par maxime tu disais parfois du mal à
défendre sur les garde adverse
est ce que il a il a d'autres
particularités défensives dont on n'a
pas parlé que tu souhaiterais soulevé à
l'eau
maxime est sûre byut désolé les gaz
étant dans le classique
non non je disais oui ça
son principal à antrim et dévots
défensif c'est ça son incapacité qui
tente d'améliorer on le voit en ce début
de saison à switcher sur des gardes mais
par contre quand il est pris au poste
clairement c'est un c'est calme c'est
carrément rock on a parlé tout à l'heure
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui a quand même
un pourcentage de bloc relativement
élevé et c'est surtout quelqu'un pour
moi qui ai un cui cui basket
nv et qui fait toutes les petites choses
que ce soit offensivement mais aussi
défensivement qui vont aider son équipe
et et qui va qui va anticiper et le qui
va tripler les attaques adverses
bent en parlait de ces petites choses
avant le podcast quand on est encore en
enregistrement de quoi tu veux parler
si on reste sur la défense de quoi quels
sont ces petites choses
by moi la chose qui m'a le plus sauté
aux yeux qu'un défense c'est je vous en
passe souvent dans le podcast ce que
j'appelle les slows twitch athlètes
c'est à dire en français je crois que ça
se traduit un athlète à réponse
neuromotrice lente
c'est à dire qu'il est eu lieu deux
sorties les deux sortes d'êtres la
dignité athlètes que la coordination
entre le cerveau et le corps est
vraiment très rapides et d'autres dont
elle est vraiment très lente en
demandant deuxième cas juste que tu as
fait dans le deuxième témoin
personnellement est moins mots c'est mon
moi aussi et le cas gaza je le vois
souvent j'ai mis un clip sur twitter
elle a su pris en deux lectures de jeu
c'est à dire il ya un jeu qui s'amorce
l'équipe adverse change de plan il a
discuté à s'adapter il a l'air pas trop
savoir quoi choisir d'être pris en de
lecture de jeu c'est juste que c'est un
switch athlètes yport guinée pas captons
quand on n'est pas capable de s'adapter
à une
vitesse à une vitesse de jeu qui est
très très élevé surtout accordé défensif
parce que saluer çà lui demande de
reculer beaucoup donc ça ça va lui sans
ça va le suivre partout ça va suivre
partout que ça va limiter beaucoup
surtout au périmètre a fait parce que
c'est là où est ce que le jeu voit de
plus en plus vite mais ça je pense que
je pense pas que ça devra être un
problème qui vont l'empêcher d'avoir une
carrière en basket professionnel
regardez nicolas vous savic peu près la
même chose
romain sur les tu parlais tout à l'heure
une bonne utilisation de son bas du
corps est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
avec beaucoup de travail peut lui
permettre de défendre allait à peu près
passablement sur des gardes s'il
s'oriente bien sortie de pick and roll
genre de show sicile drop un peu un ou
deux mètres derrière on voit de plus en
plus cette défense utilisée en nba ça me
je suis pas je suis pas super convaincu
que ça puisse à terme être un joueur à
trois joueurs de switch ça me suis je
suis je suis perplexe je peux me tromper
bien sûr mais je suis parfaite japon à
ce point non plus je ne pense pas que je
pense pas que de ce côté-là ça puisse
forcément être être un joueur dans une
efficacité particulière je le vois plus
devenir un joueur un peu spécialiste
spécialistes ou ou vraiment très bon
dans une séquence unit mais je vous mon
questionnement principal aurifères sont
liés pas sur l'aspect offensif parce
qu'on a vu on a vu avec certains joueurs
à 100 qui obligé de jouer forcément très
très vite pour être efficace en nba
moi mon questionnement il est il est sur
les aspects défensifs et sur la sur ce
que le mec pour apporter en termes de
vitesse et de mobilité
alors avant de parler de sa projection
va s'arrêter sur le son histoire romain
tu nous as fait le pedigree tout à
l'heure nous adresser le les
caractéristiques on va dire
les relations familiales qu'il avait
donc on entourage plutôt rassurant si on
se place du point de vue du ska août
maxime qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire
de son environnement de ce que tu as pu
lire autour de l'équipe d'iowa de ce
qu'il est dans le vestiaire aussi c'est
le totem de l'équipe c'est clairement le
leader s'est fait un leader par
l'exemple et c'est quelqu'un qui est ben
ari qui barreront le voit tous les as
tous ses matches c'est lui qui prend
très souvent le premier shoot c'est lui
qui prend la balle dans les moments
chauds
c'est quelqu'un qui est relativement
apprécié j'avais une interview de franck
maccary bon qui dira pas le contraire
mais qui qui venait vanté ses qualités
de leader au près et sa capacité à
attirer un maximum de ses coéquipiers
ouais ben qu'est ce que tu as eu des
informations sur sa personnalité sont le
genre de personne qu'il est web ben on
m'a dit justement qui les préparent ils
mettraient préparer c'est à dire qu' il
est très mature il est très bien
conseillé aussi on s'est toujours une
une
une épée à doute un couteau à deux
tranchants pardon d'avoir des parents
qui sont dans le milieu du basket parce
que justement ces parents là et c'est
souvent genre de pousser leurs enfants à
être qu'ils sont peut-être pas on le
pense un peu à paceman yen qui était un
peu une cata avec son fils ni que nicolo
la saison dernière mais non ils n'ont
qu'à gaza est vraiment très bien épaulé
par sa famille ses jeux le genre de
joueur qui va revenir chez lui l'été
puis qu'il va travailler avec ses
parents avec son père surtout dans le
deuxième
tout l'été développer des nouveaux des
nouveaux trucs fait que c'est quelqu'un
qui est vraiment une grosse passion pour
le basket est qui et qui a fait le
processus pré draft cette année
justement pour avoir une meilleure idée
de qui il est en tant que joueur donc
c'est quand romain disais tantôt c'est
un joueur qui sait qui c'est ce qu'il
sait faire
ben c'est vraiment un gros plus pour lui
sa joie qui veut toujours jouer à
l'intérieur de ses capacités qui veut
toujours se concentrer sur ses forces
sans justement essayer de sang croire
qui va devenir le prochain et avida
sabonis ou quelque chose comme ça donc
d'une belle maturité chez ce joueur là
j'ai écouté beaucoup d'entrevues il ya
il est un peu la casse est ce à dire
qu'il va toujours répété un peu les
mêmes choses mais ça ça veut dire qu'il
est déjà formaté niveau la communication
ce qui est plus en plus souvent le cas
exactement mais c'est quand même une
bonne chose
justement parce que je tends il est déjà
formaté mais il est déjà tous les outils
côté basket us y aura exactement son
intro donc c'est ça ça va jouer en sa
faveur
ok donc pas de pad red flag
comportementale ou pas pour l'instant
pas qu'il soit apparu pendant ces années
iowa
sur la projection puisque c'est ça qui
nous intéresse quand même effectivement
luca gaza est sans doute le favori pour
être le joueur de l'année en nba ça ça
fait aucun doute
généralement ce genre de récompense fait
que vous êtes drafté et où est ce que le
vin comment est-ce que vous l'imaginez
évoluer dans une veine billets qui c'est
peu de le dire n'aime pas trop les
grands qui ont du mal avec la vitesse
latéral on va dire romain c'est encore
une fois moi c'est mon questionnement
c'est mon questionnement on a vu des
joueurs faire carrière mais c'est kevin
love par exemple cette fois le joueur le
plus le plus latéral le plus mobile qui
soit latéralement mais il a pu compenser
avec un sens du rebond et 1 et une
qualité de tir extérieur notamment en
plus d'une présence dans les vestiaires
qui sont qui sont intéressantes
au jour d'aujourd'hui moi je renouvelle
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure je le
vois plus dans un rôle de deux solides
de solides backup au besoin avec avec
des choses très précises à faire un
pacte et physiquement sur le sur le post
up en a pas qu'une capacité à tirer
qu'il a un petit peu un petit peu
pénible à défendre mais je pense que si
typiquement pas le genre de joueur qu'on
va qu'on va drafté et éventuellement
signer pour pour les espèces défensif ou
alors on se trompe complètement cirque
c'est c'est selon l'évolution des
joueurs à coquelles on peut on peut
faire confiance si on ne peut passer
certaines certaines lacunes
s'il ya un apport correspondant la
spécialisation qui peuvent avoir dans
dans la matrice technique ben là un peu
la preuve les dernières années que les
pivots dominants offensivement poste bas
mais défensivement limiter la preuve que
ça marche pas c'est poggiali loca fort
bringuebalé d'equipe en équipe qui est
pourtant été choisie très haut alors du
fait qu'il était freshman et déjà
dominant comme un cas garza un peu moins
mais comme une caméra peut l'être
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'aujourd'hui tu as des exemples
de joueurs qui arrivent à se faire une
place en une bière
étant plutôt porté sur l'attaqué en tant
que pivot quoi bas et je parlais de
nicolas goussé vêtu tantôt nicolas vous
savez déjà fait beaucoup beaucoup s'est
beaucoup améliorée défensivement sous ce
titre les fuites sur tout mais c'est un
joueur qui a pas les armes pour défendre
latéralement au périmètre spencer hawes
je me dis suspense sur ans d'une
carrière à une bille je pense que luc
lagarce serait capable d'avoir une
carrière en nba aussi aussi courte aussi
courte soit elle je pense qu'elle est
même techniquement meilleur défenseur
que spencer hawes ça va moi je le vois
je le vois partir ce soir je vois pas
ses patins mis fin de deuxième tome et
regarde utah repêché le gros azubuike
mais ces raisons qu'on ignore encore au
premier tour l'année dernière un genre
ici aussi lucas gazan par 29e cette
année je serai peut-être moins surpris
qu'elle vous organisez bouquet partir
27e l'année dernière c'est vrai maxime
est ce que tu tu as lu ses espérances
pour la draft à lui et qui est ce que tu
es d'accord à que romain et ben quand à
la projection
ah ouais tu fais une petite popote de ce
qu'on dit rollin et ben et c'est
clairement ce que je pense ce qui peut
lui arriver mieux c'est
ces rôles c'est un leader de secondes
nunit spécialistes sur l'émission
mission plus haut plutôt offensive après
lui il est chez lui dans une interview
qui est qu'ils pensaient qu'ils
voulaient être achetés premier tour j'ai
du mal à imaginer les franchises le
draft et premier tour dans le contexte
actuel j'ai lu pas mal de réactions
quand même sur sur nos réseaux sociaux
sur twitter dire mais attendez c'est un
scandale le mec il sait jouer
il met 30 points de moyenne et on va on
va dire qu'il est trop lent et on va pas
le drafté au premier tour faut
simplement expliqué que aujourd'hui la
la nba en tout cas et comme ça c'est une
ligue qui est plus tourné vers les
ailiers c'est une ligue 2 joueurs
mobiles et du coup c'est un peu
compliqué d'avoir le profil de luca
karzaï a qu'à regarder les pivots drafté
l'année dernière qui était très très bon
qui était jeune plus jeune que gaza et
qui ont été drafté plus entre 20 et 30
romain c'est une question de contexte
aussi ça veut pas dire qui on est même
quasiment en train de dire que il fera
une carrière de pro 6 est pas en nba ce
sera forcément ailleurs
il a clairement est là clairement le
profil pour exister en euroligue de
toute façon enfin moi je voi e il ya
quand même quelques joueurs comme comme
ça qui sont d excellents joueurs de
basket mais cole hawes excellent joueur
de basket c'est parce que c'est ça s'est
passé c'est pas s'est passé pas
galvauder de dire c'est ccc réel ans au
pivot de valence au pivot monténégrins
de de valence a par exemple qui a eu
qu'à eues me semblent pieds larges
vérifier je le fais en même temps si on
est totalement là je vérifie je vérifie
vérifie la carrière dubljevic non il n'y
a pas eu de choc dans une bulle bleach
sécurité draperies été drafté la balle
et j'ai un joueur un joueur comme
dubljevic aujourd'hui qui est un bon
qu'il devrait faire dans son profil haut
niveau euroligue c'est bon c'est un
pivot très solide de l'euroligue
voilà une carrière aujourd'hui en europe
ce fut une référence cigars à demain n'a
pas de carrière nba qu'il aura
inévitablement une carrière en euroligue
d'autant plus que sa valeur marchande
entre guillemets à l'heure actuelle avec
son passeport européen fait que de toute
façon il va pas arriver en va
pareillement d'europe et joue en
nationale 2 donc en stage en sachant
qu'il est déjà mature après le problème
qu'on a à l'heure actuelle c'était un
petit peu silva fait réagir ce matin
c'est que la volée la nba repris depuis
depuis depuis deux jours au niveau des
matches de pré saison
on a déjà des analyses à l'emporte-pièce
et des tiens telle route il peut jouer
tel rookie peut pas jouer ainsi de suite
la pré saison nba n'a aucune valeur
l'analyse l'analyse à l'instant t n'a
aucune valeur la projection à l'instant
t n'a pas de valeur non plus qu'on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer pendant la
saison et on sait pas deux qui sera ou
en fin de saison
donc aujourd'hui dire regarde un peu
joué à une bille et peut-être dire qu'il
ne peut pas jouer en nba
peut-être pas je n'en sais strictement
rien tout ce que je sais c'est que c'est
un excellent joueur de basket et qu' il
le rassure ma carrière que vous
intéressante que beaucoup d'autres la
comparaison avec dubljevic est
intéressante d'autant que gros pivot qui
sert vient du bas du corps avec de
bonnes mains goy garza est encore plus
grande
c'est vrai que garza y garza fait ce
centimètre de plus mais dubljevic
aujourd'hui on est sûrs aidant petit
d'un mec qu'a pas une mobilité
extraordinaire mais qu'à une vraie
capacité à comprendre le jeu à défendre
avec ses atouts et puis bah encore une
fois je pense qu'on tourne pas autour
pas de manière de manière cohérente
addition ce point de moyenne en
euroligue en carrière doudou 6 en
carrière même parvenu on pas 12.6 en
carrière en euroligue avec pas loin de
pas loin de là des 6,7 rebonds qui vont
avec et puis les pourcentages très
correct dubielewicz et 37% à 3 points
sur un volume de tir quasiment 4 par
match
voilà si ici je pense que garza demain
tu lui dis qu'il errait carrière de
kylie la carrière de d'oublier vie de
chant en europe il sera déçu pas faire
deux ennemis et peut-être mais pour moi
ça reste plus plus qu'honorable et comme
il y en aura que je mesure je mesure mes
bon ben pour ter pour conclure est-ce
que tu où est-ce que tu le draft là
aujourd'hui
alors c'est on est on est bien d'accord
que c'est de la pure projection n'a joué
que cinq matchs cette saison sait pas
combien on va rejouer d'ailleurs co où
est-ce que tu le draft clockers quelle
équipe choses comme ce soit quelle
équipe mais c'est un peu plus dur comme
question soit déjà la position tu ne
dises f1 ce milieu et fin de second tour
entre me wade et moi j'ai en tête une
équipe qui est très avant gardiste qui
est gérée par un avant gardiste dégénéré
philadelphie qui
qui a plein de choix de deuxième tour
pendant les 20 boules prochaine amri
pourquoi pas apprendre à se prendre une
chance sur le look à gaza puis regardez
qu'est ce que tu veux je peux faire avec
lui sur le terrain je des raisons ils
sont bien gardés de défense philadelphie
donc je pense qu'il faut peut-être une
chance à prendre sur un look à gaza en
deuxième ronde bâton entre 43 et mais ce
que je peux ajouter quelque chose oui
non dans le fond la police parlait déjà
en attente au chi chi chi chi qui disait
que le ver gaza devait être repêché au
premier tour à cause qui fait 30 points
par match j'ai eu cette discussion avec
des gens sur twitter dernièrement si le
gars il m en point qu'il est sur le
terrain mais ton équipe surprend 60
points ces amourettes joie qui fêtera un
point par match mais c'est pas un joueur
qui fait gagner son équipe
donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment cette
dichotomie le qui font qu'on regarde
pour savoir si un joueur vaut pour la
peine au premier tour là c'est si si si
si si ton équipe est dans l'est moins
quand il est sur le terrain même s'il
fait un point ça ça reste que c'est un
joueur qui fait des stats iv de la jupe
un seul j'appelle cela la proposition
carlos boozer les trois sièges au
passage bravo d'avoir casé le mot
dichotomie dont peuvent cas soyez pas
fait encore oui ah oui j'aime situé via
pour bouger un petit quizz pour vous
quel est le dernier joie d'iowa avoir
été drafté nous j'ai aucune idée
dj am sure en 1989 effectivement wen a
promis un joueur hadraf depuis non c'est
pas ils sont pas réputés pour ça en tout
cas intéressant très très belle manière
de conclure ce podcast maxime pour finir
toi tu le draft aussi quand même look à
gaza on essaye tous tous les jours tous
les jours après fait un pari à prendre
sa part y apprendre il faut être comme
communion qui tombent aussi dans la
bonne organisation mais c'est clairement
c'est clairement un bon joueur de basket
bon eh bien je crois qu'on a fait le
pour de luca garza et c'est pas simple
il faut se lever de bonne heure je vous
remercie
merci à maxime on conseille évidemment à
tout le monde de suivre pour ce pour
ceux qui veulent suivre peu près les
performances de gaza puisque nous on ne
suit évidemment avec le comte envergure
pod mai mais toi plus particulièrement
tu as un oeil sur ses performances
donc on conseille évidemment le follow
sur sur twitter et puis allez voir sur
notre site il ya la fiche de gaza et je
crois qu'il ya déjà un scouting report
en tout cas il est dans la liste des
seniors qui vont compter cette saison en
nba puisque on vous a fait un guide avec
les seniors les juniors les sophomores
les freshmen qu'il faut suivre en
prévision de la draft et nos deux
podcasts les épisodes 1 et 2 sur les
internationaux les français les freshmen
voilà tout le temps récap pour vous
préparer à cette saison et pour vous
lancer vers la draft 2021 merci romain
merci ben on se retrouve j'ai pas encore
si on va se retrouver pardon la semaine
prochaine pour parler d'un joueur dont
on a des jeux dont on a évoqué le nom
dans les preview qui s'appelle khalifa
diop
c'est un joueur sénégalais qui est un
roc un peu à la garza
on commence avec du gabarit cette année
à bientôt tout le monde c'était
l'épisode 3 et suivez-nous évidemment
sur sur les réseaux sociaux sur
instagram et sur les applications des
coûte chao tout le monde